[MUSIC PLAYING]
--
JEREMY JOHNSON: We're going to
talk about IP addressing today.
We don't have slides.
We wanted to make this
more of a conversation.
I will warn you that
I'm going to ask
you to raise your
hands a lot, and I'm
going to ask you to put
your hands down a lot.
So if you need to limber
up a little bit beforehand,
get yourself loose.
The other thing is, I
might ask some questions
during the conversation.
So if you're really
eager to ask a question,
just hustle up to
one of the mics.
I think we're only going
to have time for maybe one
question during those
times, and we'll
try and save a little bit of
time for questions at the end.
But who knows if we'll
actually have that time?
And please don't
tackle each other.
OK.
So quick introductions.
My name's Jeremy Johnson.
I'm a product manager on
the cloud networking team.
And with me today I've got
Patrick Ancillotti from Vimeo.
And Patrick runs both
security and systems at Viemo.
He's a VP of Systems
and Security.
And to his left we've
got Kyle Moschetto.
He's the Director of Dev
Ops and Security for Bitly.
And very similar role.
Runs all of systems
and security at Bitly.
And to his left one of my
colleagues, Olivier Vautrin.
He is a product manager in
cloud networking team as well.
And
So with not much further ado,
I'm going to get started.
So when we think about IP
addressing in the cloud,
one of the things
that strikes me often,
because this is
my area of focus,
is that the last noN-elastic
resource in cloud
is the IP address.
Usually when you're
out of IP addresses,
you're out of IP addresses, and
it can cause a real problem.
And so this is why
we thought this
would be a useful
conversation today because I
think we all struggle with
some issues with IP addresses.
We kind of break this
down into two categories.
So public IP addresses,
so IP addresses
that have access
to the internet,
and private IP addresses,
generally our RFC 1918 space.
So we're going to start by
talking about how we think
about private address space.
And I talk to Patrick
quite a bit about this,
and Patrick's got a
pretty unique viewpoint
on the differences between
private and public IP
addresses or the lack thereof.
So I'll just hand
it over to Patrick.
PATRICK ANCILLOTTI: Can
everyone hear me all right?
I can hear me, so I'm
assuming you can hear me.
One of the things that's a
little different about the way
we treat IP addressing is
to us, functionally, there's
no difference between a
private and a public address.
Public addresses
face the internet,
but there is a
technological difference.
But we don't inherently
trust any network.
So for us, it's about explicit
instead of implicit security.
We go out of our
way to make sure
that even if something is
talking over the internet,
there's encryption, there
is explicit firewall rules
that allow this thing
to talk to this thing
instead of saying this network
that we trust is secure
is able to talk to us.
And so we spend a lot
of time thinking about--
if any of you've watched any
of the Beyond Corp. talks,
think about it like
a Beyond Corp. style
behavior for network
security in the cloud.
Google behaves this
way internally, too.
There's no Google service
that talks to another Google
service, even over a
Google network, that
is unencrypted and isn't
explicitly allowed to do so.
Did I get that right?
JEREMY JOHNSON: Yeah.
And I think Kyle has a slightly
different viewpoint on this.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: Yeah.
Our environment's a
little less complicated
than the Vimeo
environment, and so we
take a much more simple approach
to running a single VPC.
We use our IP address range in
the private space in full RFC.
And we have to map and
balance that across our
on prem solutions across
direct interconnect.
And our public IP address
concerns only revolve around
a single class C. That is the
root of all of the problems
that we face at Bitly
from a public perspective,
and we'll get into
more of that later.
But we keep an implicit
trust within our VPC.
So if you're in our
VPC, you have trust
with some obvious
basic firewall rules
to talk to just about
everything else.
So it simplifies our CIC
pipeline and other things.
OLIVIER VAUTRIN: Yes.
So we see that we have really
two different models here.
So on Vimeo side,
there's no trust
inside VPC, explicit
security for VPC
between each VM inside a policy.
And in Bitly side, you have the
limit of trust, which is VPC.
And inside this limit
of trust, everything
can connect to everything.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: Yes.
For some limited
aspects, but yeah,
everything can
connect to everything.
We put a lot of our security
focus at the border,
and then inside we realize
that if you've already
broken the door there, you're
going to get around for now.
OLIVIER VAUTRIN: Yeah.
So when we designed the solution
for Google cloud, in our mind
the VPC is limit of trust.
And we designed two
models for team security.
So there's a shared VPC that
we introduced last year.
In shared VPC, if you
have multiple teams,
all those teams are
going to be in one VPC.
You have a
centralized team doing
the management, the security
management for all those teams.
So a centralized
team of network admin
doing the management
for all those teams.
But each team can be
in different project
inside this VPC, and
so have different IM
rules or different billing.
The other model is VPC per team.
When you have one VPC
per team, then each team
will have different network
admin and different IM,
different billing, but
different security rules.
And to connect them, you
can use VPC peering that we
introduced last year as well.
You can use VPN, and you
can use VM multi NIC.
You can also have
multi NIC and NVM.
I think you are using
VPC peering, right?
PATRICK ANCILLOTTI: Yeah,
we're using VPC peering.
We enabled it pretty early on.
We're doing one of--
I'm on my third cloud migration
of the last 18 months.
So I've got a lot
of gray hair now.
I'm a lot sadder.
But during one of
the migrations,
we take the stance that
each functional unit
should have both a development
project and a production
project.
And one of the
production projects
needed to speak private--
we weren't able to add
encryption to the protocol.
So we opted to use VPC peering
because it at least gave us
some--
it moved us towards the
aspiration of everything
needing to be encrypted.
So with VPC peering, there
were a lot of advantages,
but there were some hiccups
that we ended up bumping into,
which is--
we built a tool around solving
some of these problems.
JEREMY JOHNSON: So
this is where I'd
like to ask the
audience some questions.
So how many folks
in the audience--
we've talked about the
idea of implicit trust
versus explicit trust.
The implicit trust
model would really
leverage that shared
VPC and host project,
whereas the explicit
trust model might
prefer to use separate VPCs and
VPC peering or the multi NIC
approach.
So how many folks in here use
more of the shared VPC model?
Awesome.
It looks like maybe about
slightly less than half
of the room.
And how many folks
use a model where
you're using explicit trust?
It's kind of not quite the rest.
PATRICK ANCILLOTTI:
You guys are better.
JEREMY JOHNSON: Yeah.
There are a couple of both.
There are some that
didn't raise your hands.
So I suspect those that didn't
raise their hands probably
are using maybe
smaller deployments
with a single project.
All right.
Let's move on.
So one of the questions
we also ask ourselves
while we're designing these
systems is kind of why bother
with IP addresses at all?
Obviously we need IP
addresses on the host.
But to solve some of
that elasticity problem
and some of the programmability
problems that we have,
especially when you have
explicit rule sets to manage,
it might make sense to provide
an abstraction, a label, a tag,
something like that, as
opposed to just an IP address.
So we do support some of
these concepts in our cloud.
And so I'm going to hand
it over to the panel,
and we're going to talk
about abstractions now.
PATRICK ANCILLOTTI: I'll start.
So one of the hardest documents
that we've ever tried to write
were early in our
first cloud migration.
We have a data center,
and the data center
has static IP addressing.
And we've got, as Jeremy
calls it, the number one IP
management tool in the
world, Google Sheets.
And we're updating the
sheet, and we start
doing the same in GKE because--
not GKE, in GCP because machines
are going to be stateful.
We're just doing
a lift and shift,
and then we're
going to reorganize.
And after a couple
of weeks, we start
to notice that no one is
updating the IP address
management tool.
And things are starting to
appear in the environment,
but nothing's overlapping
because the IP addresses
are all enforced.
And then we start to
deploy GKE, and everything
became completely trashed.
So GKE is wonderful, but if any
of you have ever deployed it,
every container gets an IP.
There is no way
you're going to build
any sort of human-involved
IP address management
with that in mind.
And a lot of the time we
spent doing that was more--
we kept trying to lift concepts
from our on prem data centers
and from our offices and on
prem locations into the cloud,
and being like, this
shit just sort of work.
And we all know better.
We should have known better.
But slowly but surely we
realized IP addressing is not
actually that important to us.
It seems to only
come up for us when
we want to overlap
with something
that is in a physical space.
And we've worked around
it in other ways.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: My
end goal is to never
care about IP addresses again.
We're actively involved
in a lift and shift
of a lot of our infrastructure
into GCP right now.
And so we have to use them.
We have to use IP addresses
for our firewall rules,
for our [INAUDIBLE],, for the
direct interconnects that we
have between data
centers and GCP.
That's a requirement
because we're not
going to get to
go anywhere else,
and we're not going to get any
security unless we do that.
But as we're putting
products inside of GCP,
tags are pretty much
becoming the best thing
under the sun for us.
It's logical, it's easy,
it scales really well.
You want to touch
it after a time.
And I'm going to throw
a softball question over
to you, which is we
had a lot of trouble
figuring this out
at the beginning.
Can you explain the
functional difference
between tags, labels, and
maybe service accounts?
JEREMY JOHNSON: Yeah.
I think--
KYLE MOSCHETTO:
This is important.
This is really important.
JEREMY JOHNSON:
This is something
that Olivier really focuses on.
Let's have Olivier--
OLIVIER VAUTRIN: So
it has a label, tags,
and service accounts
that are used to group IP
address [INAUDIBLE] together.
Labels are only
used for billing,
so they are not used at all
for security or networking.
So labels, only billing.
So for security and grouping
mechanism for networking.
We have tags and
service accounts.
So the big difference
between the two,
so service accounts is a
bit more recent than tags.
I think tags was really
two, three years ago,
I guess, something like this.
And service accounts last year.
The big difference
is for tags, you
can have multiple tags per VM.
For service accounts
you can only
have one service account per VM.
So that's one limit.
The advantage of
service accounts,
though, is seen as a bit
more secure because service
accounts, you can design
IM rules to decide
who can add this service
account to this VM.
So you can be a
bit more granular
into who can change your
service accounts all for VM.
So that's a big difference.
But they are used the same way.
They are used to group
VM together for firewalls
and stuff like this.
There's just one point on
getting rid of IP addresses.
So I have a bit of
an issue with that.
So I'm hearing a lot
from customers that oh,
let's get rid of IP
address and use label,
and I want to connect
red with blue,
but blue cannot be
connected with green.
Let's get rid of IP addresses
and use color or label
for all of this.
There's two issues
I see with that.
And I would love to get
your point of view on that.
The first one is there's always
a limit of trust somewhere,
so if you manage
everything, then
it's very easy to color your
source with those labels
or with those tags and so on.
But if you receive routes
from somebody else,
you cannot trust those labels.
If you receive PCP routes,
or if you're doing peering
and you're receiving some
traffic from this other
network, you cannot trust it.
So there need to
be a way, a policy
to map those labels
to those IP address.
So I don't see those IP
address disappearing,
even if it would be a nice goal.
And then that could be, perhaps,
an implementation issue.
So that's something we could
first find a work around
for that.
But as a scaling
issue, in a sense
that if you have
one label per VM
and you have a firewall
for them, basically
you have one firewall00
if you have 10 VM,
you have 10 firewall
in the implementation.
[INAUDIBLE] slash 32.
While IP addresses,
you can aggregate them.
You can do slash 24, slash 20.
And so with one rule, like
200 VM or something like this.
So there's scaling advantage
also in IP addresses.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: So we need
subnet masks for tags.
Coming soon from Google.
OLIVIER VAUTRIN: Or perhaps
for smaller management,
for smaller customer, it
might work better than
for larger deployment,
for example.
So we need to find a way to
use the flexibility of tags
and still have the scaling.
JEREMY JOHNSON: Yeah.
Something we use internally
at Google that is also useful
is sometimes we identify things.
You think about what you use
IP addresses for-- you use them
to apply policy, you use
them to secure communications
between two entities.
But you also use them
for identification.
That's primarily why they're
used in GKE, for example.
And one of the things
we do inside of Google
is we actually use a
tuple that's the IP
address and a process ID.
And something that
we would probably
extend to this kind
of pattern also
works probably well with
the lower order bits on V6.
We'll talk about
that in a minute.
Before we get into
this, really quick,
just a poll of the crowd
again, so loosen up.
How many of you folks are using
tags in your deployments today?
Of, it's great.
That's almost everybody.
How many folks have used service
accounts in your deployments?
Also a good number.
That's almost all the room.
That's great.
So by the way, I'd
encourage you--
if we're talking about
something that you really
want to talk about, walk up
to the mic and ask a question.
I think we're going
to move on into--
so Patrick mentioned
something that's
near and dear to my heart, which
is the IP address management.
This is a challenge
that we all have.
And I think that IP
address managers were not
built for clouds.
Almost saying IP,
anything about IP
wasn't really built
for clouds, right?
We have overlapping name spaces.
We have poorly
coordinated deployments
where developer A isn't
talking to developer B
and they both end up on subnet
A. This happens all the time.
So how do we avoid
these kinds of things?
We really actually need a
good IP address management
system that's really built
for cloud deployments.
And so we have to move
beyond spreadsheets.
So before we talk to
the panel about this,
how many of the
folks in the crowd
are using spreadsheets
to manage IP addresses?
OK.
The honest ones that raised
their hands is about half
of the room.
And how many folks
in the room actually
have a commercial off-the-shelf
or home-built IPAM solution?
OK.
A little less than half.
So again, there are
some people who just
aren't managing IP addresses.
OLIVIER VAUTRIN: And
Jeremy, also let's
say that they're using IPAM.
Who is using those IPAM
to manage cloud resources?
JEREMY JOHNSON: Only a handful.
AUDIENCE: Our
subnets are in IPAM.
But [INAUDIBLE].
JEREMY JOHNSON: Yeah.
So subnets are in IPAM, but
not managing individual IP
addresses.
AUDIENCE: I mean, it
depends on the environment.
[INAUDIBLE]
JEREMY JOHNSON: This
is exactly the point.
So we're talking about this
idea that IP addresses in cloud
are oftentimes ephemeral,
especially as we
move towards micro services.
So what kind of human-driven
IPAM helps with that?
So I'm going to
kick it to the panel
and get some thoughts on this.
PATRICK ANCILLOTTI:
So I probably
have to start with some
organizationnal stuff
to explain how I
got to where I am.
So Vimeo practices
engineering autonomy,
so if a team would
like to progress faster
than the rest of the
organization can,
they have the freedom to do so.
Sometimes that results in some
stuff that wasn't planned for,
but isn't the worst of, but
also isn't the greatest of.
So we, in our biggest
production project,
we use auto IP addressing.
Is everyone familiar
with when you
create a network it
gives you a bunch of IPs
and they overlap
everywhere all the time?
And once production services
are living on a network,
that's where they will
stay until you die.
So in a lot of cases, we've
ended up using auto subnetting,
not because we
planned it that way,
because truthfully, we didn't,
but because the progress
to the cloud happened
before we had infrastructure
folk involved
earlier on, which is
a great thing for the company.
And we still
wholeheartedly encourage
engineers to move quickly.
But it's something that that's
really hard for us to undo.
And at least I,
for one, would love
to have something where I could,
organizationally or somewhere
within GCP, define
available ranges
and allow networks to
be created out of those,
and reserve them,
sort of like in IPAM.
But I don't have any physical
infrastructure anymore.
So it's easy for me to say that
without having to worry about
the on prem stuff anymore.
JEREMY JOHNSON: Let me ask
one question of the crowd
really quick.
Is the distinction between auto
mode and custom mode subnects
clear to everyone?
OK, I see a few
shaking yes, a few no.
So I'll just explain at a
high level really quickly.
When you create a
subnet in a VPC,
you can have a VPC in
auto mode, in which case
every region will have its
own subnets just automatically
allocated for you.
The custom mode allows you
to choose your own range
and set your own subnet mask.
So the thing that's
interesting about this
is if you've got developer
autonomy and the ability
to build a VPC on your
own, you might really
like that auto mode
because you don't really
want to think about IP
addresses when you build out
your project.
On the other hand, if you do
have an IP address policy,
and you do have concerns about
talking to other organizations
with your project, et cetera,
then you need that custom mode.
The distinction is
even more important
when you realize that in order
to convert from auto mode
to custom mode, you have
to drain the auto mode
VPC, which means you kind
of got to start over.
So it's one of those
choices that you make
that has lasting implications.
I think that's what
Patrick is getting at.
They did a lot with
auto mode, and they
don't want to go backwards.
We're always moving forward.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: So naturally
we started with auto mode,
and then realized really quickly
that it, of course, overlapped
with our private
IP address scheme
that we had in our data center.
So we had to start back over.
And we also heard some
great horror stories
from our product team
and our [? TAMs ?] about
why we shouldn't use auto mode.
So that was always fun to
hear other people's pain.
But as it comes to our
address management,
we're using spreadsheets.
We're using Google Sheets
to track our IPs right now.
And our hope is that,
as we move forward,
we're going to need
to do that anymore.
And Jeremy said IP addresses
weren't really designed
for the cloud, and
I agree with that.
And I that if you're
spinning up thousands
of containers every
day, every hour,
there's no human
readable format that's
going to be useful to you.
The only thing you can
trust at that point
is what your API tells you
is correct this microsecond
or millisecond.
And because of that,
organizations and process
and policy has to
change about how you're
choosing to manage those.
And maybe ephemeral
is not the right word
for how I think IP
address management has
to happen in the future.
But it's something near there.
The IP address becomes
this arbitrary thing
that just exists
in the code for you
and controls certain
access to certain thing.
And ideally in a
cloud environment,
that's programmatically
done through tags
or some other
thing where you can
come in and set that defaultly.
OLIVIER VAUTRIN: So one
thing that we think is--
a typical IPAM
don't work in cloud.
So one reason for that is--
one feature of an IPAM is the
mapping of IP address to DNS,
to the DNS address.
And that is the [INAUDIBLE].
So in that sense, we are
doing already big feature
from [INAUDIBLE] IPAM.
So an IPAM for cloud need to
be very different from and IPAM
that could be used on prem.
One quick question for Patrick.
So I know that you have a
tool to manage your security.
Do you mind discussing
a bit about that,
and why had to build the
tool in the first place?
PATRICK ANCILLOTTI: Sure.
I think-- [INTPERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: So you're
talking a lot about IPAM
in terms of managing
individual addresses.
And this gentleman
was talking about how
he's actually managing
it at the subnet level.
So one of the things we're
getting really heavy in on
is using Kubernetes
on shared VPC, which
means it has IP
aliasing, which means
I've got three subnets
per kubernetes cluster,
plus Google.
And we're going private
cluster, so then Google
picks a fourth range that
they're going to peer in.
And then there's
your own internal IP
space, things like
Cloud SQL, seems
like there's a lot of peering.
So it's almost more of a
comment than a question.
And it feels like there's
still an IP space,
because my spreadsheet is
pretty big, but it's subnets.
And it's is really trying
to manage assignment,
because I'll have four to five
subnets just for the Kubernetes
cluster.
And keeping track.
And some of these are like
peered spaced, can't overlap.
And Google reserves
some of the one sub
and two space for its
peering, its magic.
A tool, I think,
would still help
to manage that level of
stuff, because that itself
is starting to feel like its
going to get overwhelming.
JEREMY JOHNSON: Right.
This is something that
I was going to bring up.
The use of IP
addresses in Kubernetes
is an area that we get
a lot of concern about.
And I would recommend that
anyone who is concerned with
that topic should go--there's
a talk over at the Palace Hotel
today at 11:40, I believe,
that's enterprise Kubernetes.
I'd highly encourage
you to go watch that.
Or if you can't
make it over there,
just find the YouTube
video after the conference
because they're going to be
talking about some things.
We're introducing some concepts
like custom mode Kubernetes
IP addressing.
And so to a certain
extent, when you
build when you build
your GKE cluster,
you're getting the
auto mode treatment.
And we recognize that
that's not exactly--
we did custom mode
in VPC for a reason.
We felt like, OK, well,
it's probably about time
we did custom mode
for GKE as well.
And so there's going to be some
more information about that.
But at a higher level, some
of the things that happens--
every pod gets its own slash 24.
We found that there that nominal
number of pods per machine
or per node is
usually around eight.
And so a slash 24 is
a little excessive.
So we want to be able to
more or less right size that.
So we're adding some
feature features for that,
and there's a lot more
information about that today
at that enterprise Kubernetes.
AUDIENCE: So I guess that's been
one of our biggest challenges.
We have a development team
that went in with GKE,
and we kind of told them, well,
OK, we'll let you do this.
And then all of a sudden they
decide to do 10.0.0.0/14,
which is pretty much the
rest of our enterprise,
and kind of had us do some
trickery with VPN and not
propagate that stuff down to
kind of give some segmentation.
But I know like, for example,
there's IP masquerading.
But that kind of goes almost
completely against everything
that Kubernetes does because
I remember talking to them.
I was like, yeah,
why don't you NAT?
And they're like, we
don't want to NAT.
So I started kicking
around the ideas--
I know this is the big no-no for
all the people in here who are
doing IP, but IPv6 because--
JEREMY JOHNSON: We're going
to hold that topic to the end.
So I have a lot to say
about that, hopefully
a lot to say about that.
But yeah, I do think
IPv6 sexism is important.
Let's hear about
Patrick's tool real quick.
PATRICK ANCILLOTTI: So when
we were converting from Kyle
to where we are now--
I'm a little shorter.
So one of the things
that we found,
there were a lot
of times we wanted
to talk to things outside.
And there wasn't a great way to
control the firewall run rule
management.
So we're big Fastly customers.
Being able to take
Fastly's ranges
and say, extending our explicit
security behaviors to the edge,
we want only these and ranges
to talk to these five origin
servers, or this group of origin
servers, or this GKE cluster.
And if we extended
it further, we
wanted to be able to say
when a GKE cluster comes up,
it can speak to this
database server.
And so we built, for all
intents and purposes,
a firewall rule
convergence tool.
So it watches all of the
assorted infrastructures,
our AWS stuff, our GCP
stuff, our Fastly stuff.
And it has a conflict
file that converges
into API-driven firewall rules.
So it'll go and say, oh,
I see a new instance.
Within a minute it
catches the event,
it creates the firewall
rule, updates all of the ones
it needs to.
And so we're able to dynamically
generate firewall rule map.
So when we talk about
explicit security,
if I was doing it all by
hand, it just wouldn't happen.
Engineers are lazy.
That's why we're engineers.
And so we call it
a border guard.
We're going to be open
sourcing it at some point.
But it allows us to care even
less about IP addressing,
because we really care
about entity security.
And so some of the
things we could easily
do with service accounts.
We could inter application
or inter virtual machine
communication.
But as soon as we extend past
what is a VPC boundary or past
what is a project
boundary, those
tend to stop being
viable for us.
JEREMY JOHNSON: Yeah.
So just to kind of summarize
this topic, I think with cloud,
and when we start talking
about infrastructure as code,
we have to be able to manage IP
addresses more based on intent
than on strict policy that
is enforced by humans.
And so what Patrick's
team has done
is they've been building
this tool for a while
to automate all that.
And as he said,
you're not going to be
able to get to this
level of explicit trust
without an infrastructure
as code model.
There's just no way that
you're going to get there.
So things might look
bad to a certain extent.
But also, given
the fact that we're
opening APIs to be able to
automate our infrastructure
nowadays, we are actually
getting to a place
where we can do more
better faster and stay more
on top of what's going on.
I think my answer to Olivier's
objection about the cloud IPAM
not dealing with, maybe,
DNS or the GCP stuff
that you may not have as
much control over in cloud
is that actually, I look
at IP address management
less as a product and
more as a set of features
or a set of functions.
And those are things that
roll out as APIs over time.
And those APIs will
facilitate the kind of tools
that Patrick is
putting together.
If you are on the explicit
security model with IP address
management I would encourage
you to look at their tool,
watch this space.
I think it's called
Border Guard is
the tool that they're building.
And it will be open sourced
at some point, correct?
PATRICK ANCILLOTTI: It also
has a really neat feature.
Again, engineering autonomy.
One of my engineers
get a little annoyed
with finding random
firewall rules popping up
because explicit
security makes people's
lives a little more difficult.
And so now it has nuke mode.
It will go through all
the rules and be like,
I don't about these,
delete it, which helps.
JEREMY JOHNSON: OK.
We're going to shift gears
one more time and talk
about public IP addresses.
It's not as controversial
a topic in a lot of cases
because for enterprises, the
public IP address is primarily
used to go fetch updates to
your operating system, security
rules or updates, and
maybe package management.
But for companies like Bitly,
for companies like Vimeo,
where you have a strong
public-facing part
of your business,
the public IP address
becomes also very important.
So I'm sure Kyle has
some thoughts on this.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: So
Bitly's technology
relies upon DNS,
which is arguably
the most advanced
protocol that's
ever been made on the internet.
So we are basically held
hostage by the IP addresses
that we've been
using since 2008.
We have one Class C. We point
every customer domain-- we have
thousands of customers, tens of
thousands of customer domains,
all pointed to two IP addresses.
So we are stuck in colo
providers and much more
antiquated systems
where they will still
allow us to bring those IP
addresses within their system,
do our BGP
advertisements, et cetera.
So we have been
leveraging and hoping
that there is some
form of allowing
us to bring our IP addresses
to a cloud provider soon.
I'm going to just bump
over to Jeremy that.
We really want that, and
that's a game changer for us
because if we can
bring our IPs, then
we can actually do things
like go to the cloud other
than just be our back end
services where we still
have this long string
of network traffic
that's going to go get data.
We want it to go
right into the cloud.
And we can't go to
10,000 customers
and say, hey, pretty please
change those two IP addresses
in your DNSA records.
Come on over.
That's a nightmare.
Nobody wants to do that.
And so being able to manage
that public space within a cloud
provider is critical for us.
And it's something
that we're hopefully
looking forward to soon.
JEREMY JOHNSON: Yeah.
So he's ribbing me a little bit.
This is a feature that
we get asked for a lot.
And it's something that
we've been working on.
Obviously the infrastructure
at Google is very complex.
And just being able to bring
in foreign IP addresses
into our system and leverage
our connectivity to our peers
is both incredibly compelling
and also incredibly difficult.
So I would say, again,
watch this space.
I think this is something
that we have been working on.
I hear every day a new use
case for this functionality,
so it's clear that there
needs to be an answer.
In a lot of cases,
we've got we've
got customers like Bitly who
have a single or a few very,
very well-known IP addresses.
And calling a maintenance
or a flag day and saying,
hey, we're going to
change everything
to a cloud IP address is
probably a nonstarter.
We're also in a world where
we're multi-cloud now.
And I don't even know what that
means for maintaining autonomy
over your own IP addresses,
but it's another thing
that we need to think about.
We've even had some
surprising use cases, I think,
where traditional enterprises
might have supply chain or EDI
connectivity to other
partners, in some cases
thousands of other partners,
where those are, again,
IP addresses,
public IP addresses
that are well-known
by their partners.
And it's something
that they can't
put their business
at risk on trying
to change those IP addresses.
And I can relate one more story.
At a company I used
to work for, we
had some manufacturing
problems due to IP addresses.
It turned out that there
were some certificates built
into the manufacturing process
that required a specific host
on a specific IP address
that was in a colo provider
that we no longer had
a relationship with.
So these are things that I
think we all probably have
an issue like this someplace.
And if you look into
your infrastructure,
there's probably someone
who knows about it,
and through heroic intervention
has solved some problems.
But these are things that--
again, with all of this,
we need to automate.
We need to build
networks based on intent,
and we need to eliminate the
need for heroic intervention
to keep our businesses running.
OLIVIER VAUTRIN:
I wonder if it's
useful-- something like this
is useful for Vimeo as well.
PATRICK ANCILLOTTI: We
put everything on a CDN,
so for the most part,
we're really lucky.
Nobody has any need
to pin our stuff.
So first time in my career
I've just been able to say, eh,
CDN's problem.
So while public addressing
is important for people
to be able to get to us,
it's not a identity for us
on the internet.
We regularly spin up additional
CDNs and move stuff around.
And so it gives us a
lot of flexibility.
There are one or two
things on our network
where we have sustained
TCP connections that
require non-CDN paths,
but we handle those
through other means
and they're not IP
address identity-bound problems.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: I'd add
one thing here, too.
Does anyone in the crowd
have that IP lock problem?
Is that a common thing?
I'm asking generally because
we don't get exposure to a lot
people that are like that.
JEREMY JOHNSON: About 10 folks.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: Yeah.
Yeah.
A good chunk, so
more than I expected.
Makes me feel a little better.
One thing I will
say about this is--
and I'm going to bring this up.
You may not like
that I'm doing this,
but AWS announced last week
that they're doing BYOIP.
And I freaked out
about that a little bit
because it was like, oh my
god, that's the thing I want.
But there is a certain
advantage in GCP's environment
to being globally
aware right away.
The fact that if we're able
to bring an IP address in,
or if we could move
to a Google IP now,
we get global availability of
that IP address right away.
It's out of the box and it
works with everything right now.
AWS's does not.
It's region locked.
So it basically moves us
from one colo to another colo
and doesn't really give
us much disaster recovery,
doesn't give us much
hot hot capability
to run multiple data
centers, or to run
the same hot data
all over the world
to lower worldwide latency.
So just some considerations
to think about
if you are in that IP
lock scenario and you're
looking for the little
things that you may not
be thinking about
right now about what
that means to move
that IP address around,
because it's nuts.
AUDIENCE: So is this a
road map item for Google?
[INAUDIBLE]
JEREMY JOHNSON: Is it a
roadmap item for Google?
I'd say yes, it's a
roadmap item for Google.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
KYLE MOSCHETTO: So the
question was, is it
a roadmap item for Google?
Jeremy into that.
And then how subtle
was I trying to be?
Like 50 on a scale
of 100 subtleness
is what my goal was there.
I'm just saying that we got
really far down the road
in a lot of places and
realized at the last minute,
oh, this really is just
a lateral move for us.
It's not a feature add.
And feature add is what
moving the cloud;s all about.
I can look at every
database I have
and every big data
application I have
and say, gosh, when
I move to the cloud,
things are going to
be so much better.
And the same kind of
goes with IP addresses
if you start looking around.
But there's things to
just think about in that.
So global is better.
JEREMY JOHNSON:
Global is better.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: If you've got
a question, go over to the mic.
That's not the mic.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEREMY JOHNSON: Yeah.
So the question is multiple
public IP addresses
per VM instance.
That's also a roadmap item.
I'm working on it.
So if you want to
find me afterwards,
we can talk about it.
So we're going to
run out of time,
and I want to talk about IPv6.
So before we completely
run out of time,
everyone that is currently
running IPv6 on your network,
raise your hand.
OK.
So 1/4 of the crowd.
That's excellent.
That's better than normal.
It means we're
making some progress.
Of the folks in the crowd,
how many plan to be running
IPv6 on their network within the
next Year keep your hands up.
Two years?
Three years?
OK.
So that's still a little bleak.
I'm hearing we need to, and--
oh, when we need to.
I see.
Yeah.
So it turns out this is a very,
very common problem with V6.
And so I have two
comments to make about it.
First of all, we
think that we've
solved most of the
problem for folks
who need public V6 with
our global load balancer
support for V6.
We do recognize that we need to
bring that to the network load
balancer as well.
But that would cover off
most of the public access
to V6 addresses that we need.
What I think is kind of
shocking and interesting--
and it really relates
to this conversation
that we've been having
about internal IP addresses
or private IP
addresses-- is that there
are a vast number of
enterprises who are just
out of IP address space.
They're out of RFC 1918 space.
I see I hand, I see a
couple of hands, more hands.
They're happening.
And happens for
a lot of reasons.
It happens because you
have a lot of growth.
It happens because you allocated
IP addresses fairly liberally
early on and now you're dealing
with a 10- or 20-year-old IP
allocation policy.
It also happens
through acquisitions.
And so to solve this, we
get a lot of requests.
We get requests to support
non- RFC 1918 space
addresses in our cloud.
That is also something
that we're working
on that will be available.
But the real answer to this is
a move to V6, and a move to V6
is tough.
And it requires
for an enterprise
to really embrace this.
I've got a couple of customers
that I talk to you frequently
who are out of 1918 space.
They would like to
move to V6, but they're
one department in a group
of many, many departments.
And the other teams that
they need to talk to
would not be as
eager to move to V6,
or they might not
be technology teams
that can take that handoff.
So we're hoping to
lead it in the cloud.
And what we plan to
do is really focus
on the enterprise use case of
the internal use cases for V6.
And so things like VM-to-VM
communication, which you
which you won't find on other
clouds, talking VM to VM.
VM with internal load
balancers, and also
the ability to talk back
to your premise over V6
via dedicated interconnect,
partner interconnect,
or over a VPN.
So that's the stuff
that we're working on.
I see a hand.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEREMY JOHNSON: Yeah.
So the question is--
I love this question.
You set me up perfectly.
So the question
is, are we willing
to consider a V6
gateway or a 6 to 4
NAT that would enable
you to run V6 in cloud
and not worry about what
other folks are running.
And I think, from
my perspective,
that's the right approach.
I would rather take
an approach where--
so [INAUDIBLE] --
I want to call him
our CTO because that's
what he feels like to us.
But he's SVP of Infrastructure.
And the way he talks about
this is the problem with V6
is that it basically introduced
a new API without getting rid
of the old API.
And that's not how we do things.
In every other in every
other part of development
or operations management,
you don't just
let two APIs hang
around at the same time.
And so what I'd like to do--
I don't know if
we'll be successful,
but with customer support
we could do this--
what I'd like to do is
to offer a V6 only option
with these kinds of gateways
so that when you switch,
you only have to deal with
one IP address family.
You don't have to
worry about both.
You don't have to worry
about securing V4 and V6.
You don't have to worry about
these label abstractions, et
cetera, with V4 and V6.
And if we just
always do dual stack,
you're always going
to have a V4 problem.
And if you've already got a V4
problem, just by simply adding
V6, I'm just adding to it.
I'm not actually solving it.
So I hope that
answers the question.
AUDIENCE: No, I never
thought about that.
But since cloud is
ephemeral, it's almost easier
to just go out [INAUDIBLE]
JEREMY JOHNSON:
So the comment is
that due to the ephemeral nature
of most of these cloud assets,
it might actually just make
more sense to fully cut over.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEREMY JOHNSON: Yes.
So there's a question
about extra bits
and what you can
do with those bits.
So interesting thing
about V6, and another area
where IP addresses
weren't built for clouds.
Most of you who
have been running V6
are accustomed to using things
like stateless address auto
configuration, or Slack.
And that means that
you're burning a slash 64.
You have 64 bits that are
basically reserved for the host
to come up with its
unique identifier.
This is completely unnecessary.
It was actually a
transition mechanism
because we have multiple APIs.
In our cloud, we're
not going to do Slack.
We're going to do DHCP.
You're going to get IP
addresses in that way,
or you're going to
statically assign them.
And so the thinking
on this is, OK, you
don't need 64 bits really.
Come on.
But we could still offer
you some bits to play with.
And so what if we gave
you a slash 96 per host?
And if you add a
slash 96 per host,
you have 32 bits that
you can manipulate
to your heart's desire.
And that's 32 bits.
That's the size of today's
internet on every host.
So you could use those
bits completely on your own
to encode whatever
process ID or service
ID or anything like
that, and still
preserve the very lowest order
bits for your host identifiers.
So suddenly you get
the same benefit
of this tuple of an IP
address and a tag all
within an IP address.
And so this is an area that
I think this isn't probably
something that the cloud
is going to solve for you.
But it would be good, I think,
if we start thinking about--
especially folks who are IPv6
usage practitioners-- thinking
about V6 for cloud, not V6
for internet service providers
or V6 for remote enterprises
or V6 for tunneling.
OLIVIER VAUTRIN: Jeremy, so
perhaps we can ask quickly,
how important is V6
4 for both of you?
PATRICK ANCILLOTTI: I want
V4 and V6 at the edge.
What I run internally is
not hugely important to me.
KYLE MOSCHETTO:
Our infrastructure
is not big enough where
V6 is a requirement.
And we've yet to have
one customer come to us
and demand Quad A records
or anything like that.
So for us, we provide 301s.
Not a ton of benefit
for IPv6 in that aspect.
JEREMY JOHNSON: All right.
Well, I want to first
of all thank you
all for showing up at 9:00 AM on
the last day of the conference.